we're talking about anything is robotic
because that from Tobias Elwood Dewey's
with us now good morning to you thank
you very much indeed for joining us
um on the program I wanted to talk to
you after hearing what the director of
gchq uh said yesterday about the threats
uh from
particularly from China and how much we
need to worry about it yeah well China
is watching what's going on in Ukraine
very very carefully indeed I mean the
unthinkable has happened we've seen the
ukrainians with the support of British
weapon systems and Americans uh actually
push back the third largest army in the
world and now there's big questions as
to what Putin may do Mighty use a
nuclear weapon what will we do to
actually bolster our support to Ukraine
during this difficult and dark chapter
that we've now entered so what's
happening with China as the head of gchq
was saying that's the long Geo political
threat in the longer term in our
lifetimes China will become bigger and
more Bolder in technological military
and economic sense how are we going to
manage that transition how are we going
to make sure we include China in the
future because at the moment there is I
think a splinter between where China and
Russia wants to go in interpreting our
International rules-based order and
where the rest of us want to go and I
think we've lost that appetite that to
determination to defend what is
important to us okay um when we're
talking about Ukraine we had a couple of
guests on yesterday and they were saying
we are running out of our own supplies
of Armory to give to Ukraine so we'll
have to we're buying stuff off the shelf
in order to give to them and as a result
we need to rethink the way we approach
war in this country it's been Europe has
been peaceful for since 1945 more or
less
um and it isn't anymore and going
forward we need to reevaluate how we
view all you're absolutely right I mean
we've enjoyed the relative piece over
the last uh 30 years we've had the
problems of terrorism But ultimately
State on state aggression hasn't really
taken place and we've become a little
bit complacent so all our own stocks our
cupboards are now becoming increasingly
uh bare it takes time to procure some of
these weapon systems they need
microchips they need you know Supply
chains to come in and if we've gifted
all of these quite rightly to the
ukrainians then how are we going to
provide their own senses ourselves where
the Prime Minister has said that she's
going to provide a review of the
integrated review of our defense posture
that must include our own procurement
our own Supply chains to make sure that
we can actually provide the defenses
that we require do we need to increase
our spending and we are already the
prime minister's already committed to
three percent of GDP hasn't she but do
we does that need to be even higher it
does indeed if we want to play a role in
protecting our world which is becoming
as I say increasingly dangerous it isn't
just what's going on in with Russia and
Eastern Europe and where China may go
becoming ever dominant in the South
China Sea it's also what's happening in
Iran as well our world if you like is
unraveling a little bit globalization is
being tested therefore we need if we
want to defend our own uh economy we
need to increase our defense spending as
well we don't make the correlation
between a strong economy prosperity and
the strength on our defense as well uh
you know what's going on with food
prices here inflation is directly linked
to Odessa so you need a Navy there if
you're going to provide a maritime Force
for example in the Black Sea to protect
those grain Ships coming out that we've
spoken about in the past our spot Chief
also talked about China potentially
owning space and the threat that that's
involved I know you've written about
this before yeah well the space is one
of those things that we just simply take
for granted every time we buy a cup of
coffee in Costa Cafe three satellites
are used because when you ping your your
card you your electronic card the timing
of it because there are atomic clocks in
these uh satellites it's absolutely
critical for our finances it's critical
for our military weapon systems to find
their targeting and so on if you take
out these systems suddenly we become
blind we're not able to communicate and
China has got their own system the bado
system and they're now encouraging more
and more countries as I understand the
head of dchq was saying to move over to
their system their competitive system
and that goes back to my point that the
world slowly progressively is Splinter
entering into two dangerously competing
spheres of influence but if they do find
themselves in a position where I'm
guessing it's not tomorrow or the next
day but but not too far away
um they can be in charge they're in
controlling space and what does that
mean for potential missiles being fired
from one part of the globe to the other
yeah exactly right I mean if you go back
to the second world war and the Battle
of Britain it was all about who governed
the space above if you govern The High
Ground if you like then you can actually
dominate what goes on beneath Now The
High Ground has moved to space and
they've not now got satellites that can
actually orbit satellites they've got
dual purpose satellites that can send
infrared and Fry another satellite and
it's all okay Corral up there we're not
able to monitor it in the way that we
should be so absolutely right and the
last integrated review one of the big
challenges was we poured more money into
that but we didn't increase the budget
and that's why we saw reductions in our
armed forces and the Army Navy and Air
Force so it is getting more dangerous
out there and space is absolutely
critical so what do we need to do well
we need to invest first of all need to
do a a reassessment of where the threats
are coming from and then what we wanted
to do to make sure not only we defend
ourselves but how we work with allies
and I think that's the big question as
to because collectively we are stronger
than China collectively we are stronger
than Russia but still you know we've
left Ukraine to do all the fighting for
example NATO has been sitting on its
hands we need to be a bit more robust
determined to be able to use our hard
power to defend what we believe in I
mean we know why that is um the nature
would say but we'll come on to that
another time before I let you go there I
want to talk to you briefly if I may
about it being quite a difficult day for
you today
yeah I I just uh appreciating that it's
now 20 years since the the Bali bombing
when you know another form of threat
sort of burst into our lives after 9 11.
so yes it's 20 years since very sadly I
lost my brother he was killed in that
that attack uh senseless attack on his
innocent people he was a teacher uh in
Vietnam the deputy head teacher of that
school and targeted not because of who
he was but simply he got was a pawn
caught up in in a huge atrocity a
different form of warfare where people
were willing to take their lives and I
don't think we've still uh answered that
question as how you prevent somebody
from being radicalized and wanting then
actually kill themselves thinking
they're going to be rewarded with a fast
track to Paradise what have we learned
since you lost your brother as far as
those sort of attacks are concerned well
personally you know every day doesn't
change the pain is still there it just
feels different I I think that we as I
say I don't think we've really got an
answer to it worryingly in Afghanistan
for example the Taliban we have taken
over we handed back the country to the
Insurgency but it isn't the Taliban it's
Isis K that's now developing there so
this threat hasn't got away and it's
important that again we invest in
organizations such as gchq to make sure
that we stay as safe as possible it's
always great to see you Tobias thank you
very much new for joining us thank you